Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill Burn?
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
August 24th,
2050 what's going on?
How or why?
How's it going?
Oh,
lovely.
End Of August for all the adult fret.
Don't fret with the global warming will have summer weather until like October.
Then we'll have epic fucking snow storms,
then a,
then a swarm of mosquitoes signaling that we're going winter to summer,
winter to summer.
That's how it works now.
I don't know why.
I don't know if fits because that's the natural cycle,
you know?
That's really all throughout the history of the war.
All they are right there.
If God's real cooling off and Haiti got parents,
there's that argument and then there's the other argument.
What do you think?
Too many Q tips be flushing down the toilet.
It is choking all the macro,
you know,
and were causing him stop putting a hairspray and your pubes.
Right.
Um,
I have no idea why.
All I know is this towards the end of this summer and this is when I get excited
for football and baseball all at the same time because the games are starting to
fucking matter.
Um,
you know,
just sucks.
My team's like 12 and a half fucking games out,
you know,
12 and a half games out.
But before we get into any of that shit,
let's talk about the,
uh,
the number one controversy in the fucking country.
Um,
my weight loss
now as you know,
as of July 5th,
um,
the Internet went crazy when they heard that I was quitting drinking.
There was a backlash and um,
whatever,
I quit drinking on July 5th,
and I've been trying,
I was gone,
I was about a buck 87,
a buck 88,
and I was going to get down to those,
lose three pounds a week over the next,
uh,
whatever the fuck that is,
whatever that comes out to like eight weeks or self.
And I was going to get down to one 62 and I was going to have a flat stomach and
I was going to have abs and people are going to love it.
Right?
So what happened the first two weeks I went,
great.
One 86 down to one 83 one 83 down to one 80 right on schedule.
Then I went to fucking Montreal and I got my ass kicked.
I did,
I,
you know,
I went on the road.
Uh,
I didn't lose any weight,
but I didn't gain any weight.
Stayed at a buck 80
in one week,
three down to a buck.
77 week four down to a buck.
74 week five down to one 71 now this week.
All right,
so I'm five and one
five and one oh belly fat,
tits.
Turn in the bus around,
driving away from the
and over to this salad.
Um,
so this week I needed to be one 68.02 B six and one and have a commanding lead
and the AFC ease of pasty titch right.
This week I weighed in at one 68.8 big time loss.
Oh six one would,
it looks so good on the calendar.
Now I'm five and two.
I did great up until last night.
And um,
my wife had somebody,
uh,
you know,
in town that we both know,
they're going to do business or whatever.
And I knew this person sort of business and friends.
So we went out,
uh,
went down to the rainbow room,
um,
on sunset and I had two old duels.
I mean that those have to be of all the empty calories out there,
those have to be the empty of stuff,
them all.
And then I had two slices of pizza.
It did that around 10,
11 o'clock.
And at my age that's enough to fuck you over.
And um,
so whatever.
So next week I gotta be down to one 65.
I don't know how the fuck I'm going to do that.
That's almost four pounds.
Probably not going to happen.
I might have to adjust my goal to one 66.
In fact,
I think I'm to,
we'll just say one 66 cause that'll be 2.8 pounds,
right?
So rather than me getting discouraged by not making one 65 will be psyched to be
one 66.
And I know what you're thinking.
Like Jesus Christ bill.
That's like when they give every fucking dumb kid at a goddamn trophy because
he,
he ran down the street with his fucking shorts on,
right?
Whatever the hell they do in gym class.
Now everybody clap your hands.
You have a clap,
say hands and gets a fucking trophy.
I,
I'm not doing that that way.
All right.
I'm taking the law some five and two.
Boy,
you got to have realistic goals here.
If I don't hit them,
then I go,
oh fuck it.
And I go back to booze and,
and uh,
nothing to not drinking and fucking working out makes Billy at tired boy
drinking.
I could stay up all night running my fucking.
Yep.
So anyways,
one 68.8.
Um,
and I'm glad that I'm talking about this on the podcast because right now I
think I look great.
All right.
I fucking,
you know,
wake up in the morning,
look in the mirror,
and I go,
God damn,
that is one,
right?
I liked the way I look right now.
It's been a while.
So a,
the temptation is to stop boop,
boop,
uh,
do they sing that song sunshine on a cloudy day?
Start hearing that song.
Well,
uh,
get some chocolate cake,
right?
You just start eating like a fucking moron.
Do a little Bingo.
Bango is Joe to Rosa says Bingo.
Bango which is a beer and a shot.
Um,
I believe Joe to want to Joe Dorros,
his friends back home coined that phrase.
Bingo.
Banga and uh,
there's a few people doing that last night at the rainbow room and I was like,
God damn it,
that looks,
that looks enjoyable.
As I look across this sticky table,
eating a surprisingly good pizza,
surprisingly good slice of pizza for Los Angeles,
California at the Rainbow Room.
Um,
seeing somebody do a little Bingo,
Bango was like,
oh man.
In fact,
the last time I did that I think was at the Rainbow Room.
I don't go there often,
but when I delve,
uh,
you know,
beer and a shot,
you've got to do it.
Why else would you go there to look at the Nelson Memorabilia?
I don't think I do.
Um,
is that his base up on the wall?
Who knows?
All right.
Anyways,
uh,
so one 68,
that's all right.
So the next week I'm going to go for one 66 and then,
uh,
then the following week I'll be what we'll see.
That'd be one 63.
I'll be a pound short,
so I'll have to go an extra couple of days and that's what I get.
That's what I get for drinking a couple of old tools,
which I gotta tell you for non alcohol,
it's not that bad.
It's not good.
You know what I mean?
The emptiest of all empty calories.
What a fucking moron.
Right?
So anyways,
I,
um,
hey,
by the way,
my phone is acting up here.
I got the fucking iPhone six,
so I'm supposed to be with all the cool kids here with all the brand new shit.
And for some reason this thing,
yeah,
I just lost all my fucking text messages,
but it's saying I have three and then it keeps telling me to sign into iCloud,
which I don't want to do.
And I keep hitting cancel and then it keeps popping up again.
If anybody knows how to make that go away,
make the world go away.
Um,
make that fucking thing go away.
I,
I would,
uh,
I would really appreciate it.
Messages.
What did I do here?
How come I'm not getting my messages?
So you know,
what you want to do is click on the settings,
the settings fucking thingamajiggy there.
I have no idea what's going on here.
I have the iPhone six.
What happened?
Did I sweat on it?
And I did I drop it in a fish tank.
They would say that to you.
Did you drop it?
Oh yeah.
It just fucking spiked it on the ground,
pal.
I said,
you're not,
you know,
you're not supposed to do that with the phones.
Yeah,
I wasn't sure.
So anyways,
um,
let's see.
What do I weigh?
I weigh one 68.8.
Uh,
so I'm going for one 66 the back of my head,
I'm still going from one 65,
uh,
and Alyssa,
I'm going to ride this bike that I just got fucking redone,
fixed up or whatever a couple times this week.
Just cause every time I look at it I hear versus voice now going through it
again.
He never got it.
He never going to riot.
That is the biggest fucking waste of money.
And you know what?
Every time I think he's right,
I picture Paul Versey on a bicycle and I just started dying laughing and I
realized he doesn't ride a
bike.
Paul Versey never rode a bike.
You know what I mean?
He likes for daughters to dance.
Anybody likes a four door sedan does not like a bicycle.
You know the,
the what,
the kind of mode of,
he's the Kinda guy that if he bought a motorcycle,
he didn't want to get a fucking three wheeler.
Right?
Am I an asshole here?
I still realize you're exposed when you ride those things.
But I think the only people who should ride those are really old bikers who
spent four to five decades riding on two wheels.
Then they're just too old,
you know,
too brittle to get back out there and they're old horse sell,
but they still love riding.
So you get them to fucking trick,
you know,
you get him the three wheeler,
right?
Seeing these fucking,
every time I see a fucking young punk on one of those things,
they're always looking over their shoulder and somebody in like a fucking German
four door sports car and that sports car,
a four door sedan is always chasing them.
That's happened to me three times out here.
I see some kid in one and he comes roaring up to the red light and he's
frantically looking over his shoulder and then some kid and like a white BMW is
chase him.
It's like fucking grand theft auto.
Actually,
I only saw it one time,
but recently I saw another kid pull up to a red heart,
red light and a three wheeler and he fucking looked over his shoulder.
So within my head,
not only was it happening again,
I added another one almost like bankers when you deposit a hundred bucks and
then they loan out that a hundred bucks,
like fucking 90 different to 90 different people and just counterfeit 800 bucks
out of the fucking hair.
Right?
Um,
anyway,
so this is the Monday morning podcast,
um,
for this week.
And uh,
I got to a,
I got to make sure I fucking eat,
eat well this fucking week I got to do this.
I got to see this thing through.
I got to get down to a buck 62.
Um,
other than that,
my fucking summers getting about ready to get fucking great or football coming
around.
I can't fucking believe it's almost here.
You know,
I am so Jones and for sports right now that I actually taped.
Um,
if you wonder about my weird breathing,
I had a fucking burrito today.
I'm just,
I'm going off the rails,
but I'm,
I'm talking about it out loud here,
so I don't fuck up.
You know what happens?
First day you look in the mirror,
you're like,
dude,
I look good.
I look fine.
Right?
Then that part of your brain goes,
hey,
let's go to Mcdonald's.
You know what I think I will.
Um,
but I actually watched Serena Williams in the semifinals of that,
uh,
Cincinnati Tournament and I didn't see it today.
I kind of got into all these obscure tournament's.
I only used to watch like the finals of the majors,
but right now I'm reading Andre Agassi's book,
uh,
open,
which I highly fucking recommend,
especially for somebody who's trying to accomplish something or if you fucking
hate tennis.
Um,
the way he describes which you go through mentally.
God,
I can't stop yawning.
What you go through mentally when trying to win a tournament or just trying to
get better or not get psyched out because you're the new kid and you're playing
against John Mcenroe's or some fucking legend.
Um,
it's an incredible book.
So I started in,
what has fascinated me more than the majors has been all these,
what I considered jerk off tour tournaments that I never paid attention to
Indian wells,
Cincinnati,
you know the clay season.
I only thought that was just the French Open and that's it.
And he was like saying that there's the [inaudible] and the grass seeds and they
got all these other fucking obscure tournaments.
And you know what I love most about them?
Plenty of fucking seats.
Jesus Christ.
You could have just walked into Cincinnati and sat down and watched a whoever
the fuck you wanted.
Tremendous.
So I watched Serena when and today she won the whole thing and Roger Federal,
so one,
and I guess he's looking young,
you know,
we'll see.
He's rewinding the clock there and a,
the u s opens around the corner.
Hmm.
They making you guys yarn.
I Dunno what's going on with me.
I don't know what's going on here.
Um,
you know what it is.
I ate a bunch of shit food.
My Body's reacting to it right now.
It's fucking just shutting everything down.
You know,
like when you close all the extra apps because it's sucking off your fucking
battery there.
You know what I mean?
I think that's what my brain's do it right now.
All right,
let's shut it down and deal with this fucked up thing.
He just putting our stomach,
this is the priority.
Everything else,
like consciousness doesn't fucking matter anymore.
So anyways,
um,
I'm actually psyched to watch,
to watch the u s open and actually to watch tennis on a level that I never
watched it before,
which is basically a to pay attention to is they,
this is the person keep hitting to the other person's forehand to their
backhand.
They hit a right Adam,
where do they put it in the box when they fucking serve it,
you know,
does the person cheat in?
I used to watch that though.
They cheated in,
you know,
if they're standing a few feet behind the baseline,
then on the second survey of the inside,
the baseline and that type of shy,
you know,
I never used to pay attention to that shit,
but it actually makes tennis way more enjoyable to watch.
And,
uh,
so whatever,
you know,
I'm not a big reader,
but I'm actually enjoying the,
uh,
Andre Agassi book there.
So,
uh,
anyways,
Jesus,
14 fucking minutes.
I'll just babbling,
babbling.
So anyways,
did anybody watch?
I was on Conan this week.
I want to thank everybody over there once again.
Had a fucking awesome time.
How great is Kona man?
The guy just rolls whatever,
every time you get out there.
And as you noticed,
I was hyping a,
the Madison Square Garden Show,
which is a obviously a big deal for me.
And um,
oh wait a minute,
I already talked to him.
I did.
I kind of talk about this.
Well,
I said who was going to be on it.
Um,
okay.
And whatnot,
whatever.
That's fun though.
That shit is always fun doing fucking panel.
It's a lot easier than coming out there and doing fucking stand up.
You know what I mean?
We are set to go
out there and host the show,
going out doing panels easy.
You just sit down and if you get someone cool like Conan,
he just fucking set me up.
Just TG up the whole time.
You know,
and then if you're on a nice Ronnie lets you go and then if you fucking fall on
your face,
he jumps in,
he saves you,
right?
They have an Andy.
Um,
so once again,
thanks to everybody over there had a fucking awesome time as always.
And uh,
all right.
Oh,
let's get to the big fucking thing of this week that affected my life.
The big controversy,
the big blowback
in this comedy climate that we live in,
which obviously what I'm talking about and I've kind of been dancing around it
for the first 14 minutes,
uh,
cause I've been debating about whether or not to talk about this and just throw
more gas on the fire or just let it burn itself out.
Of course,
what I am talking about is ESPN retracting their statements and apologizing to
the New England Patriots at 1220 in the fucking morning.
Can you fuck,
can you fucking believe that it's ESPN?
Not the biggest bunch of fucking pussies ever.
First of all,
they reported a story that was retracted in 2007 and it's that classic one that,
oh,
some guy heard a rumor that somebody said that the Patriots filmed the rams
walkthrough before the Superbowl.
That story came from the Boston Herald.
It was retracted in like fucking 2007 according to the three seconds of fucking
research that I did before I did this podcast.
Espn,
I evidently recently repeated it.
I never watch ESPN anymore.
Um,
they,
somebody tweeted it to me.
That's how I actually know about this shit.
Um,
so I guess they,
they
brought it up again is if it hadn't been retracted and proven false.
So then they had egg on their face and rather than apologizing during the time
of day when they fucking first reported it,
they did it quickly at 1220 in the fucking morning.
What?
A bunch of babies,
you know,
so there you go.
Everybody,
all you patriot haters.
Have you noticed all the,
all the paint peeling off your fucking arguments.
How about this?
With the best fucking football team in the NFL for the last 15 years,
and we got the trophies in the rings to prove it.
All right?
Other than that,
you can get on your knees and suck at giant fucking Dick with your bullshit
fucking arguments.
All of it from spygate right to deflate gate the film and practices,
all of it is a bunch of fucking bullshit.
Spygate might be the worst one ever.
If you ever do any research on it,
and Google some of the best coaches in the league talking about filming other
fucking teams,
putting buy an Oculus on him,
a veritable who's who of hall of fame coaches talking about doing it itself.
Fuck all you guys and I can't hear you.
I can't hear you anymore because I know you're just going to have to retract it
soon enough.
But by all means,
keep giving Seattle,
you know where their own owner fucks over his own fan base with the alleged
large beer in small beer building a stadium that makes his team sound louder
than they actually are and all squeaky clean.
Fucking Pete Carroll.
Uh,
yeah,
there's a fucking altar boy for you.
I'm sure nothing.
You know,
what did he got busted for doing something,
a little gamesmanship last year.
Having people report in to practice before they should have to try to get some
extra advantage.
That's all right.
That's just cause he's so dedicated.
They're,
they're not cheating out there now.
And I'm the Raiders.
The cowboys as a couple of squeaky clean fucking franchise gave me a fucking
break.
Fuck all you guys.
Fuck all your fucking year.
Fuck all of you.
All right.
We again,
I love it.
Espn with their tail between their fucking legs.
12,
20 in the fucking morning.
Oh yeah.
Finally.
I know.
It's definitely said,
let the pages with Bull Shit.
Anyway,
shameless ESPN who fanned the flames of that fucking deflate gate after they
fucking,
after they did a study and proved that it was a disadvantage and then they tried
to quickly take it down.
Oh,
you fucking horse.
Uh,
Baghdad.
That Dag.
Oh,
fuck yourself.
All right,
let's do a little advertising here for this week.
where do we got here?
What do we got?
Yeah,
a five reads.
All right,
let's try to plow through these dollar shave club.
Everyone.
I gotta tell Ya.
A shaving the old way socks a lot.
It hurts.
You lather up with cheap phone wincing as hair is scraped from your sad little
face with those old worn out razors you won't throw away because they cost so
much God damn money.
Well,
not anymore.
Everyone Dollar Shave Club sends amazing raises for just a few bucks.
And when you use them with their members only doctor commies easy.
It's completely changes the game.
Forget foam.
This stuff is the real deal.
It's magic.
Something happens when you put it on.
I feel it's hard to describe as my dick going up,
but it's um,
it feels amazing.
Don't stop.
It's the most gentle,
peaceful shave imaginable.
You barely know your shaving.
A other shaving products can leave your face feeling dry and tight.
It's awful.
But Dr cabbies,
easy shave butter is high quality stuff.
Just like their razors.
It's got organic.
All natural ingredients like pear cactus and black willow bark.
So whatever you do,
don't put it on your Dick so your skin feels smooth and fresh and moisturize
every time you shave.
It's great for cents if you have sensitive doctor cabbies,
easy shaped bottom from dollar shave club is nothing like you've ever tried.
Dr Carver's,
easy shave brown butter.
Just one more reason to try dollar shave club.
Do it today@darkdollarshaveclub.com slash burr that's dollar shave club.com/bar
dollar shave club.com/birth all right,
trunk club,
everybody,
he was a Slob or you colorblind.
Do you just hate going to the mall?
Well,
I got the thing for you.
Trunk Club summer has officially arrived.
Everybody in case you've been in a drunken stupor,
it's August 24th and that means you're too busy firing up the grill and stunning
in the sand to even think about setting foot in a mall.
The problem is you still need to look fresh to death.
Trunk Club gets it.
That's why they've taken the hassle me and out of shopping by shipping you
trunks of clothes,
a trunk of clothes,
excuse me,
that fit perfectly and make you look like 1 million bucks
or@leastathousandattrunkclub.com slash Burr you answer simple questions about
your style,
preferences and size and are then assigned an expert stylist who handpicks
closed,
curated from the best premium brands that are perfect for you.
You pick what you like and just like that.
A trunk full of handpicked close arrives at your door and you only pay for the
clothes you keep.
No ongoing subscription,
no hidden charges,
just great clothes.
And right now their service is completely free.
Get Stat it at trunk club.com/bird that's trunk club.com/berg
Trunk club.com/burr oh,
here we go.
[inaudible] me undies,
me undies,
no more sweaty balls.
Bodo Dude,
do me undies me undies.
ESPN should put on a pair and keep their clam fucking dry when they lie about
the fucking Patriots Suck Dick,
you had to apologize.
They showed it.
Got You a diaper.
Oh yeah.
All right?
Mandy's everybody,
you wear underwear every day.
That's three and 65 days a year.
Rain or shine.
Unless you have free bolden,
uh,
you need to be extraordinary.
That's the ordinary without an insane price tag.
You know,
you need it to be,
you don't have to be extraordinary,
but your underwear,
it does.
And believe me,
your balls will thank you.
Me undies understands this and that's why that is why you uh,
my,
uh,
they created the world's most comfortable underwear.
Luxury at half the retail price.
You could find a luxury,
had half the price retail price you'd find anywhere else.
Come on bill.
You going off the rails here?
All right.
[inaudible] is made from modal model of fabric that's twice as soft as cotton.
That's twice the softest.
Whatever underwear you're wearing right now,
unless you're wearing me undies,
me undies,
right up against your tank.
Me undies has tons of colors and styles and only the place,
the only place to get matching pairs for men and women.
They even release a new design every month.
Plus we all know that paying for shipping sucks.
So me.
Yeah,
me undies has removed that from all the equation and rolled it into the price of
this skivvies all orders.
Now,
they didn't do that,
but you know,
they did all orders in the u s and Canada shipped for free me undies even as a
money back guarantee.
If you don't love the first pair,
you get to keep it for free.
Uh,
you literally have nothing to lose.
Just sweeten the deal.
Me undies is offering you 20% off your first pair of panties at me undies.
Dotcoms that underwear,
biondi.com/burr.
That's a special offer for my listeners and everybody else that they sent this
copy to.
Make sure you go to me undies.com/bernie get 20% off your first order so that
they know that we sent you.
All right.
There you go.
Two more reads.
We'll do those later.
Um,
speaking of fucking me undies,
I went and visited a friend of mine today down on Manhattan beach and I have a
number of friends that have recently moved out there and they keep telling me,
oh dude,
you gotta fucking move out here.
It's awesome.
You know,
you can walk around,
everything's fucking cool.
First Time I go down there,
there's this crazy homeless guy,
right,
who will just be walking around Madrid.
And then out of nowhere he just fucking yell so loud and like throw this crazy
punch in every time.
It scared the fuck out of me.
And I knew it was coming.
He'd be just walking,
but no,
he just kept on and he just fucking throw this punch.
And every time it made me give me like a little fucking heart attack,
like what's his face in Biloxi blues.
And um,
so I'm thinking all right,
it's nighttime.
You know,
the beach is just like,
you know,
it just tree,
it just attracts so many fucking losers,
you know,
because their whole deal is like,
even if I fuck up,
I can still survive and live outside,
curl up in the warm sand,
you know what I mean?
So anyways,
um,
I'm walking down the today with my buddy,
it's during the day and it's more like family time and I'm walking down the
fucking street,
right?
And there's like these two fucking girls.
I don't know how old they were,
but they didn't have any curves yet and they're wearing these bikinis and they
got like three quarters of their ass that they don't even have yet hanging out
of the back of it.
And I'm looking at my buddy and I'm going like,
dude,
why are those little girls like,
they were like fucking 12 walking with the ashes.
What?
What is,
what the fuck is wrong with parents today?
I want to walk up to the parents to just be like that.
That's okay with you.
Do you have a watch to catch a predator?
What the fuck are you doing?
Could you put your kids' asses away please?
Fucking worst pair with it.
Literally should do they,
somebody should just come up and just,
I dunno what,
what are you fucking did dump a bucket of ice water over their parent's head and
just scream.
Wake up.
You know,
people,
if you have young children,
can you cover him up?
Jesus,
that,
that was so creepy.
It should have been in one of those fucking,
uh,
who's a guy who does it used to be a Calvin Klein,
had the creepy fucking Prefuse bressant fucking kids like locked in the cellar,
remember those fucking commercials.
And there was like the guy off camera just being like,
so what are you like to do for fun?
Oh yeah,
those jeans are kind of fallen off your hips,
aren't they?
Fucking awful,
awful commercial.
My favorite one ever.
Jim,
the taxi driver that Donal Logue.
Did you ever see when he did,
I can't find it,
but he did a parody of that and he was sitting there with like his,
his pants have pulled down answering the questions as some creepy guy off.
Oh,
it's fucking hilarious.
But then the latest American apparel,
you know,
that creepy fucking failing you get if you're any sort of a human being,
when you look at an American apparel ad,
you know,
I actually tweeted about it one time.
You're pulling up to it and you know,
he old man,
you're fucking pulling up with you.
Bad eyes going,
Jesus,
look at the ass on that.
He's only 12 right?
That's the same thing.
That's the same fucking field
today.
It's like,
what the y?
Who's the fucking creep that makes a bay bathing suit for a little girl like
that?
You know?
I don't know.
Whoever it is,
he,
he go,
he called,
he goes by uncle.
That's always a fucking,
that's always a dead giveaway,
which somebody is in their forties they're not married.
Right.
And there's still hanging out with people half their age and each and the,
Oh,
just call me fucking uncle,
whatever.
That's when you immediately have to leave and if there's any drink in the room,
don't drink it.
Right.
My fucking nuts.
That's,
that's just what I believe.
Parents,
I mean,
I,
who am I?
I don't have any fucking kids.
I shouldn't say it,
but for the love of God,
you know,
if your kids like,
if you add your kids' age,
it's like under five,
you know,
one plus two,
three.
You know what I'm saying?
That probably the math doesn't,
I shouldn't use that math equation.
I'm too fucking dumped for that.
I'm just saying,
you know what the fuck I'm saying?
And then it makes you feel like a fucking creep.
It's like,
would you get that out of here please?
Horrific,
horrific parenting.
Um,
all right,
let's,
let's plow ahead here.
The fuck else was I going to talk about?
I think that's,
that's it said all I have to,
I apologize lately,
these fucking podcasts I have absolutely nothing to talk about because I've just
been in a fucking edit room.
Um,
oh,
I can't tell you this.
Uh,
the drum lessons have been going fucking great.
Trying to get that molar method thing down.
Finally,
after all these goddamn years,
let's see if I can actually a sign in and I cloud sign in at the fucking iCloud.
What the fuck is this thing now?
I can't even look at my photos.
Yeah,
Jesus.
Does anybody know what's,
what's,
what is better than the iPhone?
Well,
what's comparable to it?
Yeah.
So anyways,
right now I'm going through that book,
the art of Bop drumming by John Riley and I'm just fucking with two,
two lines on one page and it's blowing my mind all the different ways you can
play it.
So,
uh,
I'm going to have fun for the rest of the year here anyways.
We always,
who's getting it?
Why don't I just fucking get to the Goddamn questions?
I'll fucking go from there.
Um,
somebody sent me this thing,
teams react to encyclopedias,
you know,
cause they all grew up on computers and shit and they looking at him like,
what the fuck are these ed a,
I really wanted to laugh at them that they didn't understand or thought
encyclopedias were stupid,
but they,
if it's 20 seconds into it as I was just like,
this is what I sound like,
what I'm trying to use an iPhone or any sort of computer so I can't make fun of
them.
Right.
That wouldn't be fair.
And to be honest with you,
I understood encyclopedias and I sucked at those two.
That was a big deal though.
If you were any sort of a fucking nerd man and you got to encyclopedias,
then they came out with more specific ones,
like ones that were just dedicated to sports.
I would fucking read those all God Damn Day,
all God damn day in and like,
you know,
my parents and everybody would get them get mad.
Like,
what are you going to get out of that fuck?
What are you gonna get out of that?
It's like,
I don't know,
maybe someday there'll be a 24 hours sports networks that I could get a job and
make millions of dollars a year and say things that aren't true and then
retracted at one in the morning,
support a coke habit and get some whores.
I mean,
who knows?
I did it.
There's all kinds of shit that could happen here.
Um,
but watching that just took me back to those days of having to do fucking book
reports and all of that.
Oh my God,
book report.
Now he's just waiting to do it.
There was always that fucking kid that just had the fucking ability to just go
home,
read the book and get it done.
Just get on with their life.
I would just sit there staring at the book,
walking by it every day.
Like it was like a,
I dunno Medusa's head like,
oh,
I was going to turn to stone if I fucking looked at the thing.
I really wished I,
you know,
if I could go back and do my life over again,
there's just so much shit that I just would've faced immediately and just gotten
it over with from fucking ass.
Kickings two book reports
to the molder method,
playing drums,
just sitting down and dedicating fucking three months in my life to get a little
bit of muscle memory so that it slides in eventually to my plane and just say,
okay,
the next three months are going to fucking suck with.
It's going to be slow increments of growth.
And when I come out the other side,
I'm going to be really excited.
But I just wish I had that when I was a kid.
And,
um,
it's something that I've slowly developed as I've gotten older,
especially once you get out of school and you actually get to start choosing
things that you want to do as opposed to having to do,
um,
you know,
get my helicopter license and shit like that.
Um,
you know,
back in the day that would have just ate me up.
I would've saw all his assignments and be like,
Hey,
I have to remember shit.
Fuck this man.
And I would just try and make people laugh in the fucking class and then that
would be at next thing.
And I was in summer school with a pouty look on my face.
Like I wasn't there because of me.
Like somehow I had been fucking wrong.
So anyways,
I'm,
what the fuck I'm talking about it here.
But if you can develop that,
you know,
on any fucking level,
it makes your day so much less stressful.
You have to just make a list of shit you have to get done and you wake up and
you just do it and then you look and it's like fucking 1130 in the morning,
you got the whole rest of your day.
You know,
that's a great way to spend your day.
And it's also a great way to actually develop a drinking problem because then he
got the whole fucking day.
You got no responsibility.
Okay.
Mine as well get shit faced.
Right.
Speaking of posing,
oh,
I miss it.
I do want,
I don't,
I miss it at night.
I don't miss it.
Turn the,
uh,
in the morning hours or when I step on the scale,
I don't miss it,
but I have to tell you this.
Um,
and you can call me a snob.
My wife is totally into that American greed.
And,
uh,
one of the things that I find these guys constantly spending money on,
we're just blowing money on is doing like thousand dollars shots of Cognac,
Cognac,
however the fuck you say it.
And um,
me and Jason Law had did $100 shots one time.
One time we said,
fuck it.
We both did a show.
You know,
I had sold some posters,
he sold some fucking cds and we had some merchant money and we were just like,
fuck it,
let's just take the march money.
Let's blow it on one shot.
Let's fucking tastes a shit.
And it was unbelievable.
And um,
you know,
unlike whiskeys that seem to only go up to about,
I don't know,
20,
25 years like bourbons,
like those cognacs can go.
I mean,
as far as I know,
I saw some on the Internet cause I was looking him up.
They went back hundreds of years.
Is that true?
I know wind can go back like that,
but,
uh,
I was wondering,
anybody out there currently embezzling money from a company and can recommend,
you know,
obviously I'm not going to do $1,000 shot,
but can you recommend some,
uh,
you know,
dipping my toe in the water for when I come off to sink?
Because as you were hearing this,
I'm 50 days in to my 72 day stay of a no fucking alcohol.
Marty,
50 days in,
a little quick.
It goes.
Um,
so when I come out of it,
man,
I would really love to,
uh,
um,
try something like that because with that shit,
if you're just sitting there like,
I remember when they poured the shot,
I was almost afraid I was going to spill it.
I forget how old was like 60 years old.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
this is like,
okay.
I forget how old I was at the time.
I was like,
this,
this is like 15 years older than me.
Like this thing was put into the barrel.
Whatever they do when like Harry Truman was still in the,
like,
he was just like,
I can't no,
it,
it's true.
Early.
It was Truman in early fifties,
I think.
Yeah,
the early fifties.
I think Truman was an office,
right?
Um,
well,
let's see.
He finished World War Two dropped the bomb.
That was like 46,
19 slash Jesus Christ.
Be able to fucking Internet's right in front of you.
Can you stop torture in the Goddamn listeners?
Who the fuck was president in 1952?
I'm going with Truman.
I thought it went FDR,
Truman and Eisenhower.
Um,
you as
president night t 52 and it is Harry.
Yes.
Strobic go fuck yourself.
Bam.
That guy looks like somebody I wouldn't fuck with man.
There's just something about those round rim glasses.
You know what he looks like?
He looks like the actor that played the warden in the fucking Shawshank
redemption,
doesn't he?
Or if he called up Japan after he dropped the second one.
Do you like that second one or am I being obtuse?
Um,
anyways,
the fuck am I talking about?
What am I talking about?
I'm talking about the Cognac.
Um,
I was almost afraid to fucking spill it.
And then also you didn't want to drink it really fast.
You wanted to like savor it.
So I'm thinking when I go back to Busan,
so I'm not Bingo,
Bang,
go in the whole fucking time.
I'm actually just sipping it nice and slow,
like nice and slow shade as a way to do it.
Nation,
Chabot,
um,
for instance.
So,
um,
for those of you who are my age and that you would like way the fuck is that
from where the fuck is that from?
I don't want to torture you.
That was the front of the Fred Flintstone episode.
When Fred got mugged
and the guy was telling him the reach in to grab his stegosaurs wallet.
Right.
And he's going nice and slow.
She dashed away.
You doing nice and slow.
Remember the guns like the barrel was made out of a,
like a hollowed out tree branch.
And then you just with the,
I dunno,
the tendon of a bird.
You stretched back to fucking rock.
I guess that would kill you back then.
I had no idea.
Did you know the Caveman's had pistols?
I love the fucking cave man diet,
by the way,
ever educate me a diet.
This is what caveman ate.
Yeah.
They probably ate worms and they ate ants.
They probably ate anything that they could fucking the goddamn hands on the
dirty filthy hands.
And then they died of some intestinal virus when they were like 15.
You know,
I love the caveman diet.
Like,
who the fuck knows what they ate?
Did they draw a picture of it on the inside of a cave out of,
fuck.
Do you know what that is?
They should call that our guests have the caveman diet.
All right,
well let's see.
We know Fritos weren't around back then.
Cross those off the list.
Like,
do you honestly think that there was like,
like where the fuck was cantaloupe?
Where was an avocado?
What the fuck was any of that shit?
It is walking around.
Yeah.
Try not to get eaten.
You grab a stick,
you stabbed.
So I would think that you're eating fucking roadkill.
Okay.
Yeah.
Hot and shit.
And then you just eat and stuff.
You stick in your slam and you're facing a stream.
Right?
Trying to be up river of somebody else who's down there with his fucking
prehistoric Goddam balls and tainting the fucking water.
I Dunno.
Who knows what the fuck they,
and I'm so sick of people telling me about the goddamn caveman diet as a caveman
diet.
I have an egg over easy.
Um,
all right,
let's get on with the,
let's go on with the questions here for this week.
Uh,
lady,
Fan Lady.
Hey ladies.
Hey there,
Bill.
I'm a lady fan and am exciting,
excited what?
And m seeing you for the first time in Chicago in October.
So excited.
See,
my brain does,
it's,
it's reading one sentence while it's looking at words and the next line below.
I don't want,
my fucking problem is here.
My husband has been acting weird about us coming to see your show.
I think it's because a few weeks ago we were watching one of your specials and I
said,
you are my celebrity crush out.
Jesus.
My husband chose Scarlet Johannson Nice fucking choice.
I liked this guy.
Of course I would never cheat on my husband,
but I'm afraid if I enjoy your show too much,
he's going to give me a side eye look or bring it up later.
Can you please put his mind at ease?
MMM.
Why do I have to put his mind at ease?
Why don't you quit picking people that are attainable?
P What?
Scarlet Johannson this nowhere.
There's no way he's going to get anywhere near her.
You picked some fucking dope that tells Dick Jokes in a strip mall.
No wonder he's looking at you fucked up.
How dare you make a fucking mess and then tell me to mop it up.
What is in it for me?
MMM.
What are we talking about?
I,
you know,
I'm not,
I don't put him at ease.
What are you going to do?
Run up on the stage.
I'm going to do the show and then I'm fine.
I'll be out the out the fucking
door because I'm drinking again.
Ah,
baby,
I'm drinking again.
Right.
I Dunno,
you shouldn't have said that.
Like,
look,
if my wife,
if I asked her what is her celebrity crush and she says,
Brad Pitt,
she says,
fucking Denzel or I don't give a fuck.
She might as well be picking a man on the moon.
Right.
But uh,
she named like a fucking comedian
that performs at the comedy store like I do.
Yeah.
I would be like,
well,
what the fuck you could,
you could bang that person while I was on stage the next time at the store.
Yeah.
So that's on you sweetheart.
What you should say is id.
Oh,
did I say Bill Burr?
I met Raymond Berg.
Yes.
The dead fat guy.
Yeah,
that guy.
That's,
that's what I'm so why was I saying,
why was I saying or a Billy Bush?
That's what I meant.
High on belly.
Um,
all right,
close the thing with,
uh,
you know,
I just want to have a good time at your show without worrying about him being
weird.
You created the weirdness.
Um,
all right.
Okay.
Being a landlord from a lady,
this is two,
two letters from a lady.
This is a fucking a,
this is a record here,
dear Billy butter cheeks.
Uh,
you've been talking about becoming a landlord lately.
So I thought I'd write to you about what it's like to be one.
Please don't step on my dream.
Okay?
I,
before I even read this,
I know that if it's as big a nightmare is everybody claims it would be,
no one would be a fucking landlord.
All right?
All right.
First,
know that your property will be destroyed.
You need to prepare yourself to watch it get trashed over and over again because
your tenants either by negligence,
by ignorance,
parentheses,
not letting you know when something's wrong,
until it's very,
very wrong or in spite when they vacate,
the feeling of seeing your property ruined over and over again sucks and it's
expensive.
Second,
someday you will have to evict somebody.
That sounds easy,
but it's not.
Especially for anybody with the heart.
And I know you have a big heart.
You can't hide it from me.
I'm from Ohio.
Uh,
the first time someone bursts into tears upon being served an eviction notice
and spins this sob story,
well,
you might not believe them.
You might go ahead and a victim,
but you will forever wonder if you did the right thing.
And if it's an elderly person or a disabled veteran,
forget it.
How can you do that?
You can't.
Um,
yeah,
there's no way I could do that.
Uh,
I own properties in Seattle and Portland and with all the Californians fleeing
the drought,
they were only,
they were on a wait,
wait,
wait.
They were only going to appreciate and value,
but climate change,
refugees are going to be desperate people.
And I didn't want to take advantage of their plight.
I didn't want to become that person.
Someone will no doubt,
but it won't be me.
I don't have the heart.
So think about it twice.
Yeah,
sure.
It seems like easy money and sociopath's will tell you it's no sweat with a good
lawyer,
but you have to be very detached emotionally.
I wasn't capable of that.
So I sold out.
There are so many other ways to invest your money.
Just my 2 cents.
I'm a lady,
so feel free to toss in this,
to toss this in the trash.
C'Mon.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Uh,
all right.
Um,
Well it seems like you didn't have the heart so he got out of it.
Uh,
yeah,
that would hurt me if people fucked it up.
Whenever I fucked up.
I had a dog,
I have a dog and she fucked it all up.
And before I left I got everything fixed and they were really surprised.
Um,
cause when I went to move out,
they were like going,
yeah.
Uh,
but before we move out we need to inspect that damage cause somebody came over
and fixed the sink,
saw all the damage,
like the wood moldings and that type of shit.
And one of the windows,
uh,
for,
with my dog with its separating separation anxiety tore it all up.
But I had it all fixed before I left out of respect.
And then also knowing that landlords will go down to Home Depot and spent 20
bucks and then charge me my entire fucking deposit.
So,
uh,
I eliminated that from the equation.
Um,
I'm still going to become a landlord.
I think it's a great fucking investment and I do have the heart to give people a
break.
And I also think I know when someone's bullshitting me,
um,
yeah.
You know what I mean?
Pay fucking rent or beat it.
You got to get in that mindset.
You know,
I think it is,
I think people who really are landlords and don't give a fuck and look at shit
is bricks,
bricks and mortar and our black and white probably do the best in that business.
And uh,
so I think you got to do that.
You know what I mean?
You got to watch the movie heat and listened to the narrow talk about how you
gotta be willing to walk away at any second.
You know,
you gotta be willing to evict somebody and just fucking walk away.
All right bill.
Okay.
Thank you for doing the podcast.
Easy for people to take that out.
Dah,
Dah.
You could be a little more reliable uploading Thursdays though,
but I can't.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
Actually fucked up.
That guy's joke.
He was trying to act like he was going to be cool here.
Thank you for doing the podcast.
Easy for people to take for granted slash bust your balls on Twitter,
but know that they are appreciated.
Uh,
the podcasts are appreciated.
you could be a little more reliable uploading Thursdays though,
still being a cut.
All right.
I've been steadily losing my hair for the last couple of years.
It's getting to the point where I'm thinking each haircut might be the last
before I start buzzing it all kind of crossing my fingers that this still a
comprehensive head of hair.
When the barbers sprints the chair round.
I've common as close as I can to making peace with the life of baldness.
Not thrilled about being here at 30 and women's slash guys with with hair don't
really get what a bummer it can be,
but what are you going to do?
My question,
how do I talk about this with my wife?
We have discussed it what we haven't discussed at whatsoever as she is able to
sense my discomfort with the topic and has never tried to force the dialogue.
My wife and I have an honest relationship and I'm openly discussed topics much
more awkward with actual real world ramifications.
All right,
so you've talked about having a threesome.
Ah,
all right.
It's also not like she can't see the hairlines going,
but I've built up a whole awkward wall around the topic and I'm not sure how to
slice through it.
Did you have any conversations with Nia prior to hacking off?
What was left to your hair?
Any words of wisdom from the post buzz world?
Uh,
hoping to catch you at a future?
Steve Allen theater slash comedy store Gig.
Best of luck at Madison Square Garden.
Thank you very much.
Uh,
yeah,
it was actually me as idea cause I kind of wanted to do it.
Okay.
And uh,
she was like,
you should do it.
You should do it as like,
ah,
man,
I hope,
you know,
cause the big thing is what kind of head do I have?
Because you don't want to have that flat fucking thing in the back.
You know what I mean?
We,
the back of your head goes straight into your fucking neck.
Um,
so I started saying that I was going to do it and she just kept fucking singing
this song,
uh,
data.
I've got to bring her right here.
She kept saying,
she goes,
shaved your head,
shaved,
go head.
Come on now.
Every time I would walk by and then she just yelled,
shave it.
Just do it.
Fucking shape it.
Hold on a second.
See if I can get her in here.
Come here.
I need you on the clock that
I gotta I gotta I gotta bring this,
uh,
I got to bring this one back
guy.
Right?
He's losing his hair.
He's like 30 years old.
All right.
He's almost to the point where he's going to,
he's going to shave his head and he was saying Calc,
cause I did it.
You know what I mean?
He doesn't see,
but he doesn't talk about it with his wife.
And she knows that he's sensitive.
So as he's built like this awkward wall,
but it's just totally obvious.
And they were saying,
did you ever have a conversation with Nia about shaving my head?
And if,
as far as I remember,
it was your idea,
right?
It was,
you know,
that song used to sing.
Okay.
No,
Dave,
your head shave,
shave your head.
Yeah.
And I would laugh.
I forgot about that.
Yeah.
And then I finally went ahead and did it.
I will tell you this,
when was the first time,
I don't want to get me to come over here.
When was it that you did it for the first time?
How long ago?
Get on the mic here.
About nine years ago.
It was the first time I did and then when I did date night,
they asked me to grow it back and I was like,
and I was like,
I was like going,
well there's not much to grow back.
And they were like,
yeah,
we'll fill it in and we'll fill it in or whatever.
So I was like,
all right.
And then I grew it back and then I kept it for a while because I started
thinking like,
this is why I'm getting a acting,
which is the dumbest thing you can do.
Right.
It's not because of my skills,
it's because my hair.
Yeah.
Balding,
which was stupid.
And um,
I will tell it's the greatest fucking thing.
If your body is the greatest fucking thing you'll ever do.
And I'm actually reading Andre Agassi's book where he was talking about,
I didn't know he wore a fucking hairpiece and one time he was in the shower
before the French Open final and he was in the shower and his whole hairpiece
came apart so they had to fucking glue the thing back together.
So he went out in the court and played this guy.
He could have beaten the whole time.
He was worried that his fucking hair piece was going to come flying off like a
three stooges episode,
you know,
fucking embarrassing.
That would've been,
that would've been terrible.
Yeah.
He,
he talks about how,
uh,
I guess Brooke Shields finally convinced him to do it and he did it and then he
felt great.
Yeah,
I will tell you that it's the greatest,
it's the greatest thing ever.
The greatest fucking thing.
You could add all these fucking guys going out and,
and like fucking slicing up the back of their heads.
I have in the shit vacuumed out and then paratrooped on top of their head.
Like most of that shit.
It works for a minute.
But then the thing is,
is like those,
they go,
the hairs in the back of your head don't,
um,
those things never fall out.
So if you put them on the top of your head,
then you're okay.
But the thing is,
is you still have all that other hair up there that's gonna fall out so that
shit falls out and then you need more fucking replacements.
And then sometimes you can actually,
it can like not work as far as I know.
So I'm a big fucking,
uh,
I dunno.
I'm a big,
I think it's a fucking way better move.
Okay.
I actually say it's the man move.
You fucking dealing with the,
the hand you've been dealt.
You just do it.
This is what I look like.
People go,
what the fuck for a few days?
And then they think you look w when they see pictures of you with hair,
they think you'll look weird and then you're free.
You fucking free.
So rather than going to the barber every time and putting your head down as he
cuts it and then open your eyes going,
what does it look like now?
Just fucking get it over with.
Get it over with dude.
Shave your fucking head.
What are you saying?
Nini?
It,
yeah,
shave it.
It's fucking awesome.
Then you love it.
And then what's great.
No matter how late you wake up for work,
you can just throw on clothes and get there.
No,
no,
you didn't take a shower because you don't have bedhead anymore.
Bye Bye.
All right.
Okay.
Hey should,
oh,
am I going to talk?
We're,
I mean,
yeah,
actually considering doing a project together.
Okay.
Might write a book,
but it's not the kind of book you think.
It's not about us.
Um,
it was that dumb is that dumb.
Did get in a business,
the wife,
why would it be,
you know what I mean?
Okay.
I know.
You know I ever get divorced to take him for half.
I got,
so I might,
she might as well fucking be helping me create,
you know,
she could tell she's not in the room anymore.
All right,
let's,
let's read it.
Let's read the last of the advertising.
Shavia had,
buddy,
you're gonna,
you're gonna feel fucking great.
You will feel great.
And this is the thing,
dude,
someday,
who knows?
And I'm going to lie to you someday.
If they just came up with a fucking pill and you popped it in there and it made
you,
gave you the shits for three days,
but all of a sudden you fucking had this fucking great head of hair.
I,
you know,
even that I wouldn't do,
I'd wait 10 years to see how people fucking,
you know,
if their livers fell out.
Uh,
actually no,
I gotta be honest with you.
I'm a lifer with the shaved head.
I am,
I don't give a fuck.
What are you going to do?
You know,
this is what I look like.
Deal with it.
Another great thing is if you fucking shave your head,
people sometimes think,
you know,
a little bit of mixed martial arts,
but then they look at your perfect ears and they're like,
no,
he doesn't.
No,
he does it.
Uh,
but that might be just enough time to give you to run away.
That's a true story.
All right.
A legal zoom,
everybody.
Um,
do you want the government to decide what happens to your property?
And minor children.
I love how hardcore fucking legal zoom goes right out of the gate.
I mean,
just immediate like Jesus Christ.
No,
of course I don't.
Uh,
if not,
make the commitment to protect your family with the living will.
A last will living trust today.
It's national.
Make a will month@legalzoom.com and doing the right thing has never been easy.
They've created a better way for you and your spouse to control your,
uh,
your family's future.
Checkout legal zooms,
new last will and living trust bundles.
The more you plan ahead with wills,
trusts,
and powers of attorney,
the more you save.
Even if you're confused about all the options,
don't let that hold you back.
You can use their online resources in estate planning tool to help you figure
out what you need or get specific guidance from legalzoom's network of
independent attorneys in most states since they're not a law firm,
a don't procrastinate when it comes to protecting your family.
Get legal help.
You can count on@legalzoom.com today.
Don't forget to enter in burpee.
You are are in the referral box at checkout to save even more.
That's legalzoom.com promo code bur bur are legal,
zoom.com legalzoom.com/burp no legal zoom.com sorry.
No slash bro.
All right,
and finally,
lastly,
but not leastly,
stamps.com everybody,
most of us are trying to find more time every day to get things done so you can
let trips to the post office slow you down.
No you can't.
Sorry.
So you can't let trips to the post office slowly down.
Jesus,
what am I talking about now?
You don't have to.
Thanks to stamps.com for he's a jolly good fellow with stamps.com buy and print
official us postage right now from your own computer and printer stamps.com
we'll send you a digital scale automatic that automatically calculates the exact
postage you need for any letter or package.
Any class of male.
You'll never waste valuable time going to the post office again,
do everything right from your desk with stamps.com print the that you need.
Put it on your letter or a package.
Then just hand it to your mail carrier and you're done.
I use stamps.com to send out all my posters and if could figure it out.
So can you right now use my last name,
birth for this special offer.
No risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in [inaudible] that
stamps.com enter bar.
By the way,
if you guys are going to go to a comedy club out here,
you got to go down to the comedy store.
Man,
they got a line around the block and I think I know why.
Listen to this fucking lineup I was on.
I went on on the main room Friday night and I walked in.
Mark Marin was on stage who then brought up David spade who then brought up Joe
Rogan and then I had to go on after all of those fucking monsters.
It's unbelievable,
dude.
The comedy store lately.
It's get your ass down there.
Everybody's been fucking coming through and I'm just insane,
insane fucking shows down there.
And it's fun.
You don't win.
Rogan has been working out like a maniac on the,
on his fucking act.
He was destroying in front of me.
You know,
it's funny as a comic that's been doing it this long,
you know,
I always watch Rogan,
but I was talking to somebody,
but like subconsciously you're hearing the laughs and at one point he was
getting this level of laughter that I had to end the conversation and then start
making a set list.
I'm like,
I just can't just walk on stage after this fucking mayhem that's going on out
there.
I actually,
I need a game plan here.
Um,
which is another fucking great reason to go down there.
You know what I mean?
All those guys pushing you.
Um,
all right,
let's get,
let's read the last couple here.
Alright.
Bullied at work.
Hi,
Billy.
Buff boy.
Uh,
I work in an office with several young females,
so several young ladies.
Um,
sounds good,
right?
Ron?
I'm the only young male here.
So what's wrong?
They like to gang.
You said gain g a I n gain up on me.
It's gang and g a n g gang up on me and constantly put me down or make fun of
me.
It started out all fun and games,
but some of them have recently become very aggressive and are almost verbally
attacking me.
What,
what I don't understand.
What is the problem here?
When I have brought it up to them,
it just made it worse and made me more of a target.
Yeah.
Dude,
you never got bullied before.
The last thing you say to a bully is he,
what you're doing is really bothering me.
Just so you know.
Uh,
what can I do to make this situation better without getting management involved?
I don't want to get them fired or anything.
I just want,
yeah,
I just don't want to be the female punching bag anymore.
Thanks.
Um,
I don't understand what is going on here.
What are they saying to you?
If they're giving you shit,
you got to give him shit back.
You know what I mean?
Come on,
man.
Defeat in a fucking woman in a verbal thing.
You know,
you know where you have to go,
but he can't go there because then they're gonna rat you out to the boss.
This is what you'd do.
Just walk in,
right.
Just walk in with your eyes squinting
one day.
You know,
looking like an idiot.
Just walking just in Blinken a lot.
Just squinting
and walk right up to the one with the smallest chess.
Okay.
Don't do that.
I was going to say,
just do those.
She goes,
what are you doing?
Just go try to see your titties.
Yeah,
that's so childish and stupid,
but unbelievably effective.
Okay.
And I think,
I mean I'm not going to speak for women here,
but what I really think it is is women realize the unbelievable power that they
have over guys with their looks.
So if you ever indicate that there was a flaw in their looks or that they're
starting to slip,
it really fucks with it.
It's too mean.
I,
dude,
I don't have fucking sympathy for you.
What did they just verbally abusing?
You?
Give him shit back.
Give a,
what are they saying?
We're right back to me.
Right back to me.
What the fuck or what are you one of those kids?
Did you always wear a helmet when you ride a bicycle?
Did you have play dates?
Are you part of that fucker generation,
dude?
Come on,
man.
Snap out of it.
Yeah.
That's just how it would just be like,
Hey,
what?
What are you just going to stop being such something you got to do?
You've got to shoot something across the bottom.
You got to give him shit,
dude.
You got to give him shit.
Just point it whatever they're wearing and be like,
oh my God,
what did you get that?
And then just keep walking.
That's all you have to do.
That fucks up a woman's Day.
What do you mean by that?
Do I think you just give it back to them?
Just give it back to him,
dude,
I,
I don't you fucking grow a deck and give it back to a man.
Come on.
Okay.
This is,
this is like this whole fucking thing.
I'm guessing you're a younger person.
Oh,
you said a young male.
Yeah.
You've been completely beaten down to the point where you're now,
you know,
we went from men beating women with fucking mop handles a hundred fucking years
ago to now this,
this to the point of a complete overcorrection that you're going to sit here and
allow yourself to get verbally abused.
Okay.
Because they're women.
I do like the fact that you don't want to be a rat and rat him out.
This is what you gotta do.
Okay.
Treat them with the same level of respect that treating you.
Uh,
the,
I would avoid name calling and I would definitely not curse,
but other than that,
I would be just as fucking mean as they are.
I just do it.
It's so easy to fuck with.
Okay.
The next time one of them says,
do you just offer some gum and just keep doing it?
And just being like,
listen,
I'm not trying to be a jerk.
I don't know what you've been eating late,
but I've noticed it over the last few days and just invent in their head that
they have this fucking halitosis it,
that's,
that's it.
And then you divide and conquer.
It's a joke dude.
It's not that fucking hard.
You know what I mean?
Just tell them which one you think is the most attractive and why and let the
other two losers fucking deal with that and the other one will actually feel
good that you said it about her,
so now she's not fucking with you and then the other two are pissed at the other
girl and then you got some infighting
and don't bring it down to,
let's just say,
you know just you got to,
she has a certain level of class that the other two of you lack.
I'm not trying to be a jerk and he just fucking leave it nice and vague like
that.
That's all you do.
And all I'm doing is taking a page out of their book because women are masters
at that vague mind fuck.
And then walking away.
It's a work of art.
I didn't even think they have to work at it and they just born with it.
It's tremendous.
Okay.
I probably goes back in the day from when they were dragged around from cave the
cave by their fucking hair.
They had to say something that mind fuck the Harry Douche bag that was about
ready to take advantage of them so they could walk away before he fucking
dragged them into the cave.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
I'm just fucking talking all kinds of shit here.
All right,
let's wrap this thing up here.
Career advice,
dare bill of Burr.
Ah,
that's a great one and accurate.
I've been a high school teacher for the past seven years,
but my dream has always to become a professional writer.
Oh,
that's awesome.
Okay.
You know,
dude,
that would be a great life.
You're molded some young minds and then you became a professional writer so far
I'd,
he said so far I don't have a teaching job for the upcoming school year.
I'm considering no longer having my own classes and instead becoming substitute
teacher for the school year.
This would give me more time to write and submit my work to literary agents and
hopefully get a big publishing deal.
I've had some success so far with writing a published short story and a
nomination for a literary prize.
Dude,
what the fuck are you waiting for?
Okay.
How many more signs of landing and neat this is like Columbus.
When he fucking sailed over and he saw some tree branches in a couple of birds
you're going to get,
their problem is that my wife and I still have a lot of student debt that we're
repaying and substitute teaching does.
Teaching doesn't pay nearly as much as being a regular classroom teacher.
I've put off my dream of becoming a writer for years and I think now maybe the
time to metaphorically pushing all my chips.
I might lose,
but I might win now.
Dude,
there's no way.
There's no way you lose when you go after a drink.
You don't.
It always leads to something better always.
All right
dude.
Fucking substitute teacher teach and be a fucking Uber driver.
All right,
and you know,
eat at home.
More starving artist.
I slept on a futon until I was 36 I don't fucking regret any of it.
I told you that story a zillion times in this podcast.
I was dating this,
this woman and I said I had a spot I had to go do and it paid $8 at the comic
strip during the week.
Tuesday night I went down there and I came back,
I tried on a new bit and I was doing it and afterwards I was at home in my
apartment and I was doing this silly dance in the kitchen cause I had a new bit
and I was psyched because I had gone through this period when I wasn't coming up
with any new material and she was laughing and then she got a sad look on her
face and I said,
what's the matter?
And she said,
I wish I had a job
where I only got paid $8 yet I came home and I did a silly dance in the kitchen
and I never forgot that dude so that,
you know what I mean?
You're going to have to suffer a little bit,
but a substitute teach Uber Dude,
you Po,
you got a short story published and you got a nomination for a literary prize.
Come on man.
You know what you're supposed to do.
I don't even have to go through the rest of this fucking thing.
He goes,
my,
all right,
I'll get to the whole thing.
He said,
you know,
pardon me.
Fights against the dream and insists that I have to do the responsible thing and
keep teaching.
Fuck all of that.
Fuck all the responsible thing to do is to listen to your heart.
Uh,
my question for you,
either in your,
either in your career when you were trying to build an audience and make it as a
standup comedian,
did you struggle with the financial strain of chasing your dream?
Did you ever have to choose between a good paying job or doing stand up our
heart?
How hard was it to work at a shitty job just so you can chase your dream?
Did you ever think that maybe you are wasting your time,
any advice are occurring?
I think I answered all of those.
Um,
it wasn't hard to work at the Shitty job because I was always thinking about the
exciting job I was going to do afterwards.
Um,
and every night that I just went up on stage and if it just went moderately
okay.
I couldn't believe it.
I couldn't believe I have to be honest with you.
Like,
okay.
I,
I couldn't fucking believe that I was actually doing it.
That I was actually,
I had a dream and I was making it happen.
And I still remember the first time I really went on stage and I actually got in
the zone for what was considered a zone at the level comic I was.
And I only was in the zone for about eight seconds.
Okay.
Um,
I was at Nick's comedy stop in Framingham on route nine.
It doesn't even exist anymore.
And,
um,
I just got on this roll of laughter that I was actually able to pause and
fucking be in the moment and enjoy it rather than be like,
oh my God,
what's my next joke was my last job.
And,
um,
that
fucking feeling can carry you through a fucking shitty job for a week.
Chasing to get back on stage to feel that again.
And then the first time I got $5 for gas money for Eddystone.
I've told all these stories.
Friday stone,
the excitable boy,
that's what he went by.
Um,
I did a room for him and he gave me $5 gas money.
I probably spent 10 to get there and I couldn't fucking believe it.
And I was like,
I did that.
And they gave me this.
I couldn't fucking believe it.
At what point,
just listen to the sound of my voice.
I'm talking about this.
Have you ever had that level of excitement doing any other fucking job?
That's what it's like when you're,
you,
you go after a dream job.
So nothing,
nothing is worse than not going after it.
Okay.
And doing the responsible thing and all of that type of shit.
And then you sit in your house with all your responsible stuff.
Fuck.
All of that
is financially I did not do the responsible thing.
And yeah,
I told,
I've said all these stories,
I fucking east eat spaghetti every fucking night with a can of fucking prego.
Then bunch of bread and I would just fill myself up on that.
Or I go to Denny's and I get the five stack of pancakes and just poured my
stomach like concrete so I wouldn't have to eat the whole fucking day and do
standup in some cafeteria at some fucking college.
And quitting never entered my mind.
I just kept trying to get better at it because as bad as some of those gigs
were,
the great ones were way better.
So you'll have all of these stories just in a literary way.
So with,
without a doubt,
you have to fucking do it.
And um,
I can tell you right now,
man,
like with what you,
what you've already accomplished.
Like to me,
I would be thinking like,
I'm gonna,
I can affect way more people and make way more fucking money and live a fucking
dream being a professional,
right?
I mean,
right.
that'd be unbelievable.
Began.
Unbelievable.
So not to say there's anything wrong with teaching,
but if teaching isn't your dream,
that's just the job you're doing.
So I'm not shitting on teachers out there.
So one of the most underrated jobs and of course,
most underpaid jobs ever.
Um,
but any,
I'm just trying to amp you up here,
so go out and fucking do it and email me when you get published because,
uh,
I think you're gonna I don't think you,
you know,
I'll give you a bunch apo get bunch of other shit writers and you won one thing,
but you got two things going on here.
All right.
Give me a fucking break.
All right?
You just need to push yourself out of the fucking Bush.
Not The bush.
The Nest.
The Bush.
That was oddly gross.
All right.
That's the fucking podcast for this week.
Um,
ah,
this is fucking Burrito fucker with me.
But the hiccups,
what did I do?
Um,
back
on the horse,
the Horse back the horse.
I go to the gym everyday.
It's just the gut part.
And if you don't want me saying,
Hey,
go to gym everyday,
you can't.
All right,
you hit the gym hard.
Go after your dreams.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll check on Thursday.
See Ya.